a face tracker if it doesn't know who
you are it shoots you with a
tranquilizer dart oh shoots my wife
every day with the Tranquility
gets her nice and quiet
[Music]
okay so now imagine you're at your home
you're on your property you're in
Connecticut okay and you look up and you
see I will never be in Connecticut
something truly horrifying okay you see
that there's a bear on your property
yeah
but is he is he drinking a soda pops and
now what you're well no so you know you
you actually decide you're like okay I'm
gonna go inside be safe and then I'm
gonna investigate what the hell's going
on and he discovered that the bear is
actually filming him and his wife on
their property
it's a YouTuber bear has a little
harness on it no way and the bear has a
[__] camera on it yeah it's a GoPro
it's a chest mounted so it hasn't it has
an ear tag a collar with a [__]
camera on it pet bear no no is this a
cartoon
no this is actually in real life okay
this is Yogi Bear it's the beginning so
what what the victim discovered was that
it was somebody from the state
was using the bear to take a legal
surveillance of their property what yeah
well how did they train the bear to go
to their house to go to 74. why not a
deer or like yeah something nicer so
he's quite out of drunk claiming the
state department the department of
energy and Environmental Protection put
a camera on the bear that they knew
frequents their 117 acres and they were
doing an unreasonable search of their
property so they just put a body cam on
a bear yeah they did they put a body
camera why bear turns it off kills the
family
no evidence
why are these people so important
um well they're just saying that the the
officials are illegally surveilling
they're probably they hate Bears so when
they can colonize their property they
have been illegally feeding bears
apparently according to the state for
the years oh so they want to catch up
smart bear sting operas so they're not
like no I wouldn't give a damn about
their property it's like we keep telling
them stop giving them pumpkin pie our
bears are getting overweight they don't
want to eat Natural Foods they keep only
eating pumpkin pie well they just leave
pumpkin pies on the windowsill and then
the Bears come on oh see Connecticut
Connecticut
doesn't say that the bear had friends oh
I hope he's a good question when we were
in Zion they have these like little
squirrel chipmunk things running around
and they have signs everywhere this is a
national park don't feed them and they
show like what they're supposed to look
like versus what they actually look like
and they're really overweight oh [__]
and so and they're [__] guilty bro I
made so many squirrel friends yeah the
national parks because I had a big bag
of corn nuts and I couldn't resist
eating them because I wanted them to get
as close as possible to me and I had one
on my [__] knee while I was giving
them corn nuts they're so cute I did
that on Mount Charleston
so we had a law Breakers no we had
raisins and then yeah like I really want
to touch them so we would just lay
raisins out until it was on her and then
when the Chipmunk would come on around
like oh
you're not afraid of it biting your hand
no not really really it's worth the risk
dude I had I was in Bali and we did this
monkey Forest thing that's different
those little [__] are thieves
monkeys are different though yeah they
are different breeds
Steve I don't know if you know this
might not be the same genius yeah I
think so they got a little human brain
in there I don't think they're
mischievous they're just acting like
monkeys did they climb my body he
climbed my body you should go after my
glasses does it feel weird when they
that's really weird when they have a
little pause on you yeah it's really
it's really odd but it's also kind of
cool yeah it's kind of cute [__] band
of monkeys right yeah big fan yeah
they're trying to steal your cameras
trying to trying to steal anything shiny
on you are they trained to do that or is
that just Natural Instincts like this is
smart as hell I think there's nothing
and they're playful they like to mess
around so I think they'll do things just
to like see what the reaction is and
they take your [__] and they sell it on
eBay they like to Monkey around yeah
[Laughter]
this guy is basically saying that he he
believes that they knew that the bear
was going to come into the property they
it's like sending in a robot I guess he
says with a camera on you can't do that
without getting a warrant by the way and
so he is suing the states that's the
same as putting it on a robot that's
what he says that's what he says
sure it's the same it's definitely if
they just use satellite to look at it
yeah isn't it the same as like those uh
Google Maps cars with 70 cameras like
driving around town anyways isn't that
the same thing I think so like is that
illegal that's legal right but that's
not around
property doesn't you can't see it like
I've tried it before because there's
private roads like gated communities
yeah yeah when you go there you can't
even see the homes you can't go in there
you're going I see imagine bark thinks
that like there's a Google car in Area
51 just like driving around making sure
or it's just a bear did you see those
Chinese spies in Alaska that got caught
taking pictures they're like oh we on
tourists yep of a military base they
were pretending to just be sightseeing
you know what they should do they should
post the pictures of the tourists and
then the pictures that they took like
I'm just curious to see what they
actually look like yeah top secret and
show their captions
like their descriptions of it do you
guys got cameras all over all over your
house yeah all over all over just in
case
inside and out oh yeah wow I can't have
no cameras inside brother
the camera's coming in because it's like
okay like who's coming up to the door or
around or or hopping the fence behind
and then inside the house is like one if
they get in through the door uh there's
a camera facing inside or if something
happens while I'm in the house there's
cameras you guys have ring or Nest I
have ring neither did you see that ring
got caught for employees watching
People's yep wow what do you mean what
do you mean I bet they all don't don't
they all watch I asked them everyone
watch the footage I have one spot it's
supposed to but yeah there's like
there's dudes that would tap into
women's like ring cams and they would
just save the footage
spank bank after that happens a lot
though dude every time my [__] goes off
which is like once a month at least like
it's always just me or Nikki opening the
door without like unarming the alarm
yeah like every time but it goes crazy
it makes your blood freeze you're like
oh [__] yeah well I have I have uh that
too I have ADD too so I have cameras add
ad ADT I got 88 I got ADHD he's relating
to you doing that I have so many layers
of protection it's like Plus
plus your bare hands bro yeah plus I I
put a jar on the doorknob every night
bucket of water on top of the door booby
traps for real yeah dude like a face
tracker if it doesn't know who you are
it suits you with a tranquilizer dart oh
shoot my wife every day with the
Tranquility how to get her nice and
quiet
there's um private companies security
companies out there that will install
like remote control [__] hidden wall
automated like like oh those are cool
ballistics
ballistics ballistics
are those donuts
Donuts
thanks for coming dude hell yeah I think
it's your fault oh we're talking about
this private doors okay the ballistics
okay so so yeah there's there's like for
this is because I was trying to see like
okay so normal folks like us we get you
know ADT we get Brinks or we get these
different Security Programs
so I was like what do these rich folks
do he's quick well one they have their
own security service that stays at the
house yep two if they're not home some
of these guys they install in the walls
like shotguns or like ballistics where
like and then he could you could you
could control it from your home so it'll
be like oh [__] you have an intruder
right you can hit a button and blast
their ass through the walls
it might not be legal but these guys are
so rich they probably have so much like
this is it legal in Nevada though
lawyers and all that stuff that can help
them Castle law states you could
probably have those actually so some of
these companies they're International
right and they're like check this out
they're like they have this South
African car right it's like a
Mercedes-Benz luxury car super [__]
crazy and they have flamethrowers that
you can operate from the inside or
remotely on your phone that's the
Batmobile we're like if some robber
comes up he tries to break the window it
just burns them because your door goes
like that and then so the whole car on
the side so it just torches up but what
if you make a mistake where it's like no
Meemaw don't touch the door yet and then
she's just
there is a law here I mean I was
watching his lawyer Channel and they're
saying you can't set traps in your house
what you can't even put sharp [__] on
your fence like if a burglar was trying
to get a scale your fence and they cut
themselves is that in California you
know yeah I purposely put sharp [__] on
the fence because we had an Alleyway
next to my house and then we're just
chilling in the pool having a good time
and homeless people they just keep going
like this so is barbed wire legal then
you can't have that on your unless you
have a prison yeah who voted for this
[__] [__] because I promise you
you guys like Mommy all the robbers
voted against it for exactly most of us
the reason for that that they say is
that
um if it because there's a risk that it
may not be a burglar having to do that
it could be a cop it could be like
emergency services oh that's the reason
why they like saying I've never seen
paramedics try to rob my house yeah
and it sounds like a really good excuse
to get you to disarm yourself the the
smart guy work around
the smooth brain workaround is you have
to make it look like you didn't mean to
put it there smooth brains for dumb
people though I know it might be stub
the spikes that I bought are the same
kinds for like the birds you know you
don't want like bird [__] and whatever
yeah it's that kind of thing and I put
it across the hole you have to be able
to legally prove that it was for a
different reason odds for the birds but
it's I'm trying to poke a [__]
homeless man but here you are so holy
cooking should be in prison for life for
what he did oh yes yeah yeah yeah he
should go to jail stay in Chicago
Illinois yeah yeah set them on fire and
they have video footage of him setting
the traps him doing it they haven't said
the rights there was this one that was
not so harmful I thought was really good
there was a double door trapdoor thing
where like you know when you go into
like a store right uh some in cold
places it's like one two and then
another one because it's like the
weather and [__] oh yeah so they have
one where it's like you get through one
and then there's another one there's
another hidden one where if if fits like
an intruder then it opens up so it's
like not a door that's it's like a
guillotine door like it shuts down oh
[__] it traps them in between the
hallway yeah that one you have to that
one I was watching you have to be it has
to be a room that they have to break and
Enter to access if they can walk in it
normally then you're it's on you again
is it your whole house breaking it yeah
exactly is it illegal to put a large
area rug over a deep hole
say that it was under construction yeah
yeah I didn't want people to see it look
tacky yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
didn't want the ring guy to see it
[__] hate bad guys man dude bad guys
are winning and the [__] because some
good guys are protecting them yeah do
you think do you think some of these bad
guys like they talk about these laws and
they're like dude we're really lucky do
you think they're appreciated I bet they
are or do you think they're just like
why do you think robbery is up and like
burglaries up like there's like business
is great you didn't let go do you think
criminal spider gets a second amendment
so they can try to disarm people I don't
think the laws even apply to that that's
what I'm saying that's like they know
they're not gonna like follow those
rules I don't even think they know how
many amendments are there yeah yeah I
don't know
especially for this podcast you got into
the First Amendment for sure first
amendment is the right to vote the right
to rob the right to kill yeah those are
those are my amendments
damn these guys agree with this too yeah
so don't heat your don't heat up your
doorknob unless you want to go to jail
[Laughter]
[Music]